welcome to best life 30 your 30-day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can just watch
this video or if you want to sign up for
the entire series for free and get the
companion bonus worksheets that go with
this video check the link in the
description below alright so today is
day 23 and we're gonna learn how to
better brand yourself you have to
advertise you have to advertise in your
career to blow your brand up you cannot
not advertise and save money it cost me
probably 400 should I even say a number
this big or do I lose everybody 400
million dollars we have estimated is
what it cost me because I didn't
advertise for the first 20 years of my
career but before you spend one dollar
in advertising and and even if it was
wasted it'd be a great dollar to spend
even if you don't get a return you
should do it but before you do that what
you need to do is spend a lot of time
energy and resources on branding I made
a mistake here not spending more money
in advertising I made a bigger mistake
not spending more time energy and
resources on branding and you are making
a mistake if you do any kind of metrics
on did it convert did it pay off
branding will not pay off zero you will
get a zero return if you don't Brant
okay you will get a zero return for
branding in the beginning you will get
you will never get a return on
advertising if you don't bring branding
is a must it is senior to advertising a
big part of what makes a company
successful is whether or not they have a
brand BR a nd almost misspelled it and
brand people think well it's the
communication you know what a brand is
more than that the reason Rich Dad is so
valuable right now is because it is an
internationally known brand the same way
as Trump is known as a brand and the
real question on a brand is not just
communication see if a brand makes it
easier to sell when somebody says Rich
Dad
all I think I heard of that or I know
what the guy stands for and all this so
what a brand really is is the entire bi
triangle if you're gonna create a brand
especially in a world that's overcrowded
with advertising communication the web's
ipods print blogs i mean there is so
much competition now for a person's time
it really is more important that you
become a brand so there's a shortcut
communication like if I see the word
Ferrari you know you get a picture of
something in your mind it's a whole body
effect but if I said Hyundai or Kia you
know car they probably just as good a
car but you get a whole different
emotional effect just by the brand name
so I'm not saying Hyundai's are better
or worse than a Ferrari but I'll pay
more for a Ferrari than I will for a
Hyundai I don't know 100 by the way I
own a Ferrari what does it mean it's a
shortcut communication like if I say the
word Apple you know some people think of
compute computers and some people think
of red apple but for the guys like me
who I'm an apple fanatic you know the
brand means a lot to me I love Steve
Jobs he's one of the best entrepreneurs
in the world right now and if I say the
word Marine Corps Marine Corps is a
brand it communicates everything the
mission the team the leadership a style
the message and the Marines have a
saying we're only looking for a few good
men and women and that means we just
don't want to be like the army we have
to position ourselves away from the arm
of the Air Force and the Coast Guard
than the Navy so brands are so vitally
important as a communication tool
especially in today's over communicated
to world there are more people competing
for your customers mind their time you
know how many blogs can you read how
many magazines can you read how many
television sets can read how many games
can you play in all this so today if
you're gonna be an entrepreneur it
becomes more and more important that you
become a brand when you're driving down
the highway and you see a coca-cola
billboard and then you see a big giant
bus in the city with a coca-cola
advertisement on it do you think
coca-cola knows where the sales are
coming from are they able to track
the sales from the billboards or the
sales from the bus or the sales from the
movie theater obviously not right they
do branding as advertising and they have
a ton of money and so they are just
shooting their brand out everywhere and
they are everywhere all the time right
omnipresence now when I first started
out with Fit Body Boot Camp and I wanted
to make this a global brand I didn't
think about how I can brand myself I
just wanted to do one thing I wanted to
sell one franchise location and when I
sold one franchise location I said I'm
gonna sell another franchise location
and then I sold a third franchise
location and the fourth and a fifth and
now we have hundreds of Fit Body Boot
Camp locations worldwide we've created a
national brand and it's become a thing
but before you can make yourself a thing
before you can make your business a
thing you gotta first just focus on
direct response marketing direct
response marketing is accountable
marketing I know that it feeds the ego
to see yourself as a brand and a public
figure and but listen if you were to
just start putting your logo or your
brand all over the place how are you
gonna be able to track where the money's
coming from you're not gonna be able to
track that and if you can't track it you
can't quantify it the best branding you
can do in your business is to make a
promise and to keep a promise when I
created Fit Body Boot Camp international
my goal was to take personal training
and reduce the cost of personal training
I wanted people who couldn't afford
personal training to work with the
personal trainer at a reduced rate so we
went from one-on-one personal training
to the bootcamp style and the whole idea
there is one coach or trainer and many
clients and that reduces the cost that
each individual person is paying I knew
that there was a problem and so I
brought in a solution whatever brand or
whatever business or idea that you have
right now I don't want you to think
about branding I want you to think about
solving a problem you go and you solve
the problem and everything else will fix
itself because you'll sell one and then
two and then three and so whether you're
building a franchise or you're building
a media marketing agency or maybe you're
just a one-off location selling cupcakes
make the best
the cupcakes you can on the planet and
when you do guess what happens people
talk about you I'm an aspiring chef I'm
in culinary school right now I'm trying
to make a sign a little sharpening knife
I love this idea I'm gonna give you a
tremendous piece of advice that to many
people that are ideological and don't
actually play in the game push against
but I believe in it the most
you should go sharpen knives for five
restaurants for free for free okay yep
like what like I spoke for free for the
first 13 for no actually I paid for the
first one good that's how it also for
mmm 13 of the first 15 times I ever
spoke I spoke for free including paying
for my flights it's one thing to do free
work it's another thing to do free work
with heavy strategy when I do free work
I try to think of two things how much
exposure is it like Tyler will tell you
sitting right here one of the only times
I still do free work is if it's massive
exposure there are 49,000 people in the
audience among a lot of explosions you
know like like it's live on you know
it's dawning this soup I like like I'll
pay somebody to put me in a Superbowl
commercial right like when they when I
get exposure or and that's where I'm at
now in the for you when you pick these
five restaurants let it be the biggest
restaurants in your 30 mile radius
let it be the kindest let it be somebody
who has the biggest Instagram following
and maybe like whether you know you
never want to give with expectation but
it's it's okay to ask you're like hey
I'd love to sharpen your knives for free
and then like you get in there and the
vibes are feeling good maybe like hey
listen like I hope you enjoyed it like
wouldn't mind to take a picture for my
Instagram which then makes them say oh
we'll put you on our Instagram like you
can be thoughtful and do it the right
way but if nothing else if you do it for
free for five people you've established
that you do it word-of-mouth is a
remarkably fascinating thing strategic
strategic free work is one of the great
moves in our society one of the people
not understanding about video okay
what are they not understanding about
how powerful it is for their business
their brand new and ultimately their
message to impact people it's always
that same question what's the ROI on
social media
right what's the ROI now the funny thing
is your business work in service my
business work in service literally lives
off of social media so there's obviously
an ROI but the problem is we live in a
world where we want everything to be
measurable and there's a beautiful
Einstein code that says not everything
that counts can be counted and not
everything that you can count counts
right and we live in this world where
everything needs to be measured like oh
that video has a million views how many
cells did you get through that but it's
like life doesn't work like that there's
a load of adverts and billboards on the
street that the biggest brands pay for
that don't convert into direct sales do
you think that coca-cola looks at the
billboard out there and goes how many
people saw that advert today and how
many people bought coke I'll go look
because of that advert they don't have
that number it doesn't exist and they're
one of the biggest brands in the world
but they still do it so social media
video is just a new billboard mm-hmm and
the biggest brands know that the more
you see it like I mean this is funny I
saw this thread so a big billboard
outside of my hotel that has all the
Jenners and the Kardashians wearing
their Calvin's have you seen it well I
saw it straightaway this morning then I
saw it on Instagram and then I swear
everywhere so already I've seen in three
places now I don't need women's Calvera
underwear but the point is that I've
seen it in a million places so anyone
who's not using video hasn't understood
that more people are gonna see video
than anything else
and notice that video is so much better
than a billboard you can say so much
more right so for me it's just a lack of
seeing opportunity there's a there's a
great I think this is a old tale it's
not true
but but it's told that when Nike first
went to India they went there and it's
not like it's any any sneaker brand its
its ass nice story and when they first
went to India they saw everyone was
barefoot so the first reporter came back
and said or there's no market there
because no one wears trainers and then
the second reporter went then he said oh
no one wears shoes and then he came back
and says we've got a huge market out
there right and it's the way you see it
that someone soared no one wearing shoes
there's no mark here but another person
swore everyone not wearing shoes as a
marketing and that's what video is that
you can sit here and debate the ROI on
video for as long as you want
the truth is every major brand has
invested in a front window that may not
translate to direct sales or work or
whatever it is but it does do you think
every brand should be using video every
bride should be using video a lesson in
branding whenever trying to brand
yourself or any company if you change
your brand from what it used to be at a
rib right away you can get resistant so
most people when they get a little
resistance but mostly what optics in
when they stop but over time if you keep
branding yourself in the new brand then
eventually it catches on like I used to
not have much fitness stuff so when I
fire to start putting Fitness stuff
people are like what does hold is
Fitness now eventually people just
associate that with you and they forget
there was a time when you didn't do it
so that's a good tip on branding you
have to have thick enough skin because
it's kind of like when Facebook changed
every time they changed their interface
people go nuts oh I hate this but in
three months later they can't remember
those plenty and then when you changed
you a new one they say no we like the
one before but that one before is the
one they hated because it was a change
from the version of you know one before
but Mark Zuckerberg smarter than people
that's why it just keeps changing it
whatever is better and then people
eventually like it same when Instagram
changed their logo snapchat changed
their you know people always a lot of
people have low OH meaning low openness
to new experience they automatically
hate anything new what do I worry about
I worry about brand control my brand is
huge now right and one thing I fight
with every day I want to make sure I
don't dilute the brand
I don't do anything makes any major
mistakes because any mistake or hurt
your brand and so those are the things
that keep me up at night just making
sure my brand remains strong and so
that's a good message for all these
young men and women watching your show
just make sure that your brand is
everything and you will always be able
to make money if your brand is strong
even if you go bankrupt
if your brand is strong you'll be able
to still make some money Donald Trump
proof that he bounced right back
the look where he is today you know he
went through that phase came right back
because he kept a brain strong and
that's important we spoke to the creator
and the the person who's maybe looking
to work on their personal brand and
stuff on the flip side there are a lot
of old-school brands that have sort of
like a dinosaur mentality when it comes
to social media and and new-school
marketing and you being one of the
disruptors in that area
you know you've mentioned you mentioned
Nike no Nike and and how you weren't
even wearing anything that was Knightly
what what sort of message you have to
the guys at the top let's say that are
scared to evolve and they're hesitating
because they're used to what works for
them I mean I look I think Nike is the
Nike has one of the strongest brands in
the world because they're willing to
take caches on a video like that and the
reason why someone like myself works
well the Nike a company like Nike is
because like it's about an ethnos as
much as it's about a product which is to
say that it's very little about the
product um you know I think Apple
computers like their commercials are
never about their products products
they're about an idea and my philosophy
I'm branding and marketing as a whole is
like if you sell the idea people will
invariably buy the product so all the
marketing that I do is always about
ideas it's never about products one of
the things I've learned over the years
is that people may have tremendous
potential but because of the way they
are perceived by others the way other
people look at and value think and talk
about them they never get a chance to
use that potential so I began to study
what it is about branding an image that
sets you up to be successful and far
faster than most other people let me
define a brand first a brand is
basically a promise when you have a
brand it's a promise that you make and
are known for keeping to the person who
you are asking or trying to influence
human beings decide emotionally and
justify logically if you have a good
personal brand people aren't willing to
pay you more for your product or service
and argue less a brand always begins
with your values what do you stand for
quality of excellence responsiveness
teamwork innovation leadership then when
you're clear about these you build a
tremendous personal brand by starting
with the principle of integrity there's
no better reputation you can have other
than for people to say that when they do
business with you you always fulfill
your promises the answer for success is
to do what you've been hired to do and
do it now this expands into every area
of your interactions with others here's
the rule everything counts everything
that you do either creates and builds
your brand or weakens and destroys your
brand everything cannot you blue came
out with a product in 2000 in 1980 a
product that was based on an innovation
to introduce ruble as a strap it seems
very common today motor rubber in 1980
was a real courageous move it was even
the provocation
people say hey on a gold watch rubber
because people didn't know rubber comes
from a tree robos natural rubber is is
very comfortable it's very flexible and
rubber is very resistant and it's
waterproof so finally it's ideal for
what but in those days it's people
thought it's a provocation it's a and
then we blue could not evolve they
stayed on a product and I said we are
not a product we have a message first we
have a concept and the concept is fusion
why because in 1980 when we put gold
together with rubber we created a fusion
because golden rubber never come
together
they were together only one time in life
during the Big Bang then everything was
in one and then rubble go he went away
and said okay I go now on my tree and
God said okay I'll go and rest in South
Africa under the earth and since then
they never met till people take them and
connect them so I said you know made of
fusion and fusion must be our message
must be our philosophy must be our
religion and once we have this religion
clear and it made his name Fusion then
we can develop further products that not
necessarily need the rubber anymore
because fusion goes further away than
just rubber it can be carbon it can be
ceramic whatever so I was capable to
free you blue from the product and give
you blue a message and from that message
new products were born and that was the
most important element in the revival of
the brand it's to take it away from a
product concept and to give it a brand
message and from the brand message where
then later born in 2005 new products
I gave it's this you know all this
information on you about fluffy and I
thought this was a joke so I tested it
to see if it was a joke it said if you
google fluffy it's you and then it's a
bunch of bunnies and I googled it and
that's exactly what happened how did you
come up first and then three or four
down as a bunny I've been well I've been
branding the fluffy name for over 15
years I caught on early that you know
what there was something there
and I just went with it because I used
to get upset when I'd say the joke and
then people would come up to me
afterwards and they wouldn't say great
job Gabriel they would say hey good job
fluffy and I'm like really
six times I said fluffy ones but fluffy
is what stuff yeah so after a while
getting tired of of being upset over it
I just embraced it I started marketing
myself that way where I'm always the big
guy with the Hawaiian shirts and I'm
fluffy and so uh you're everything
eyes'll
yeah everything has and then see that's
a problem to a lot of entertainers they
keep changing their looks but before
they become famous it's like you need to
have a level of consistency you need to
be able to market yourself need to be
able to brand yourself if you got a good
product who's gonna find out about it
unless you sell up the right way brother
you wouldn't do the Puff Daddy thing and
change your name to fluff one day you
know what I could do it I could do it
now just because now people know who
they love they're right but back then no
I mean you got to get yourself to a
point where everyone knows who you are
and then you can pull that move what is
it that you see for yourself what are
your goals long term as a business you
see some golfers you know you see the
likes of Arnold Palmer or they see the
likes of Jack Nicklaus and you see how
they've built their brand over the years
and I think the most important thing for
an athlete is building their brand on
their performance on their field whether
it be on the golf course or on the
football pitch for the basketball court
or the tennis court or whatever it is I
think that's the number-one thing right
then you can't do one without the other
exactly you know so I think that's the
most important and then you know if you
do have that performance on the field or
on the golf course I think then it's
about you know having a great team
around you and knowing what you want to
achieve and and I think a lot of it is
you know when you're satisfied you know
when are you happy you know what are you
ever gonna be satisfied or you know I
think that's something that's a big
question work for a lot of people now
I've got a special bonus cup that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the best live thirty
questions of the day it's not enough to
just watch a video you have to do
something about it so pull out your
worksheets and answer these questions
and if you don't have the worksheets yet
get them for free by checking the link
in the description below here we go
question number one how would you define
what your brand message is number two
what's the problem that your brain
solves and number three how will you
market your brain to get
more visibility and if you're doing the
best life 30 challenge with me put a
hashtag best live 30 in the comments
below we want to celebrate you have a
profession and procrastinating so now
I'm at a point where I'm trying to like
publish all these articles start this
frantic website but I don't have like a
following on any social media channels I
think the success barrier for me is I'm
I'm wearing to have the right bike you
know these like 30 articles and every
day I want to write article and I'm
gonna publish it and no one's gonna read
it right no one is gonna read it
[Music]
like but that's the start dude that's
the start like you put up content and
nobody carries at the beginning it's
it's consistently following through like
30 articles in 30 days isn't gonna be
enough it's it's every day forever and
maybe it's maybe instagrams not the game
forever but it's if you have if you have
a message and you want to get it out
there creating content is the best way
to do it
so my Instagram last year I started
taking it seriously with 7,000 followers
or something we started posting six
times a day me it was me doing
everything at the start right even
though I had people on my team I did
everything at the start and then once I
figured it out then I hired people to
help me do some of the the work right
but I like to understand it first
so for you to be looking at creating
content has to be part of your marketing
strategy whether it's video for YouTube
or Instagram content or Twitter or
LinkedIn wherever you gonna be and then
we're in your calendar you're gonna
spend time creating the content and at
the beginning nobody's gonna look at it
one because they don't know who you are
yet and two because it's not as good as
it could be like go back and watch my
first videos they weren't very good they
get better with practice even Alex from
making videos for TDs like salsa videos
and thought leadership videos there was
a period of time what three years ago
four years ago when were you making
videos regular with TBS no no no videos
in front of the camera oh like four
years ago four years ago and we worked
every week him I would teach him like
he'd be in front behind the in front of
the camera I'd be behind his like no do
it again and say it like this and he
slowly got better and then and then he
stopped
and he got back to it like two weeks ago
three weeks ago a month ago a month ago
and the first three days he he made it's
like what is this like this is like you
took a big step backwards
has it been it been so long that he
hadn't done it for a while right it's
like you're okay you're capable way more
than this like I'm gonna get feedback on
this because you already know watching
the back that you're better than
than this right and then the next week
was already better the next week was
already better right but it's it's
continued to put out the content
especially on the platforms like while
up YouTube so much is the content that
you make now Liz forever and so if
you're making it now it may only get a
few views but if you keep getting a few
views and every month to keep getting
more few move views and then three years
later four years if I still getting more
views every piece of content you make
not only makes you better as a thought
leader as a creator but also is another
brick that you're building your
foundation that can be discovered
forever okay so the fastest way to grow
the business with is partnerships and
alliances referrals so finding people
who already sell to your target market
and find a way to get them to refer you
whether it's a paid thing or just they
like you know you and they have
customers who are facing those issues
that's the fastest way right next would
be a paid ad strategy but you have to
have a business model attached to it so
whether it's you creating it or you hire
a company that that you know you work
with that you know who your target
audience is you know what their issues
are and you run a paid ad against it
that you can convert to ROI
I don't like paid ads just to build
brand just to build following because
you're spending money I hate spending
money until I'm making money so I want
to see a business model attached to it
that you have coaching consulting right
so so your paid ads have to lead to
coaching signups not just I gained 20
followers on Instagram right the organic
stuff is the best game but it's the
longest game so making content every day
maybe pays off in six months or nine
months or a year right but by that time
you won't be out of business
all of questions but let's say you're
you gonna publish my thirties blog
articles and I'm gonna be focusing on
getting all the followers and all these
video channels or you just going to just
gonna level five circles in these select
Facebook pages
yeah and Facebook organic is the worst
so you have content now what do you do
with that content there's the paid
strategy that if you're if you're like
what's an article what's what's an
example of an article toxic relationship
and you're gonna help them get out of it
or find a better one or like what are we
gonna get in your coaching session great
okay so if you have an article about
social anxiety and you can help coach
people through that then that's content
that can become an advertisement that
leads to a lead capture and a free call
with you for 20 minutes to then lead to
a paid session so you take you take the
article it's 400 words or whatever and
you block you chunk it up into different
potential ad copy but then you could
have business next week and people
calling you but you're paying for every
view on that you're not worried about
our Ganic on that you just smashing it
up right so even with TDS we'll take
some content and then run ads against
certain demographics right Organic
Facebook is the worst you'll get nothing
from Facebook
I'd be looking at it's written articles
so you put it on your website which can
help with some SEO but but then I want
to have it in micro form on Twitter I
want to put it as an article on LinkedIn
Instagram I try to turn it into like
pieces of the article and just take a
picture so if it's social anxiety you
show either you like frustrated or a
stock picture and then give me your
thoughts fire captions people really
underestimate how good captions are the
written captions are on Instagram even
though it's a really visual medium
that's where I would start you'll have a
video so you can't turn into a YouTube
yet but I'd love to see you just speak
your message into a camera too and post
it if you want to join the best life 30
challenge click the link right here
below me or if you want more videos on
how to
brand yourself better check out the
playlist right there next to me continue
to believe and I'll see you soon